[Musique]
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez à
l'instant on est ensemble pendant une
demi-heure pour l'invité de 8 30 sur
france info la radio et sur france info
canal 27 avec comme chaque matin dans le
studio jean françois achilli
bonjourbonjour céline et bonjour avoue
marc fesneau bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin vous
êtes le ministre de l'agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire alors on va
parler de la rentrée bien sûr rentrée
politique puisque le conseil des
ministres de la rentrée aura lieu demain
rentrée sociale également mais d'abord
si vous le voulez bien revenons sur
l'été qu'on vient de traverser qui a été
terrible à bien des égards la sécheresse
la canicule et les orages vous avez
annoncé hier une première série de
mesures pour le secteur agricole est ce
que ça arrive pas quand même un petit
peu tard par nature non puisque pour
pour ce qui est du court terme et la
gestion de crise il faut qu'on soit au
moment où on peut distinguer ce que sont
les effets de la crise pour essayer de
répondre donc c'est une première série
de mesures je rappelle qu'on parle de
production qui pourrait à certain nombre
d'entre elles n'ont pas été encore
récolté je pense au maïs je pense aux
tournesols sait déjà que ça va être en
baisse on sent on sait qu'on va avoir
des difficultés donc c'est pour ça qu'on
a un premier train de mesures et puis on
verra à l'automne une fois que la saison
sera terminée pour compléter
éventuellement les dispositifs qu'il
faudra qu'elle ce qu'il est la
difficulté principale est liée à
l'élevage pourquoi parce que les
éleveurs généralement mobilisent plus
tôt le fourrage on mobilise plus tôt les
prairies ou le maïs qui produisent
eux-mêmes or on a une production de maïs
qui est plus faible et de on a des
prairies tous ceux qui ont été sur les
routes de france cet été n'ont vu qui
ressemble plutôt à des paillassons cas
des prairies et donc on a un problème
d'alimentation animale et donc une
difficulté pour les éleveurs à trouver
très rapidement maintenant de
l'alimentation comme ils le font en
hiver sauf que là on est au mois d'août
et donc c'est ça la difficulté
principale devant laquelle on est marc
fesneau ce sont à peu près tous les
secteurs à part peut-être le la vie nous
les grandes céréales sont tous les
secteurs qui sont impactés par ce serait
par nature où il avait dit qu'il faut
aider tout le monde finalement il faudra
pièce par pièce si je peux dire secteur
par secteur regarder les conséquences
lavigne alors ça n'a pas été la
sécheresse pour la vie vous l'avez dit
vous avez parlé des orages ça a été
plutôt la grèce il ya eu encore des
épisodes de grêle ou d'orages violents
je pense dans le gers ou dans le sud de
la france ou encore c'est évidemment et
donc secteur par secteur regarder alors
les grandes cultures ça occupe une
grande partie de nos surfaces une partie
a pu être récoltée dans des conditions
qui sont plutôt corrects je pense des
céréales à paille donc il faut regarder
et l'arboriculture et le maraîchage
pourquoi parce qu'il ya un sujet d'accès
à l'eau et une difficulté pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux avoir une
production qui soient au rendez marc
fesneau et juste avant de rentrer dans
le détail des mesures secteur par
secteur une vision globale quand même de
la gestion de crise est-ce que vous avez
été suffisamment sur le terrain on a le
sentiment qu'on a vu beaucoup gérald
darmanin parlait des 1 110 aller voir
les pompiers s'inquiétaient de du front
des feux de forêt on a en a assez peu vu
le ministre de l'agriculture auprès des
éleveurs auprès des cultivateurs très
inquiet par cet été hors norme j'ai été
à la fois sur le terrain début août
encore la semaine dernière enfin j'ai
été sur le terrain tout l'été à la fois
pour constater puis c'est d'évaluer les
mesures les mesures que j'ai évoquées
hier que j'ai présentée hier de son
fruit d'un travail de terrain que j'ai
fait avec les équipes du ministère les
équipes des services déconcentrés de
l'état donc le sujet c'est à la fois
d'être sur le terrain et en même temps
de regarder concrètement ce que ce que
ce qu'il en sait s'est il exclamé crise
est là marc fesneau il faut communiquer
au maximum où il faut être extrêmement
solide et rhin il faut les il faut les
deux je pense qu'il faut communiquer
pour montrer qu'on est au plus proche
des difficultés quand il ya un épisode
de grêle quand j'étais dans l'allier
j'étais dans les alpes-de-haute-provence
j'étais dans le maine-et-loire l'autre
jour bref il faut à la fois être sur le
terrain parce qu'il ya une il faut
montrer aussi aux agriculteurs puisque
c'est d'eux dont on parle l'occurrence
qu'on est au plus proche de la réalité
qu'on essaie de percevoir ce que sont
leurs difficultés puis 2e après il faut
aller là plus discrètement faire un
travail de fond qui est un travail de
réponses aux dix aux enjeux qui sont les
leurs parce qu'à des attentes du tout de
suite du maintenant sur le web ne sont
pas ou il ya eu cette conférence hier
pour présenter les premières mesures
sécheresse vous allez mobiliser le
régime de calamité agricole or ça ne
concerne pas tout le monde non alors il
ya le régime de calamité agricole et
bien que ceux qui en bénéficient pas les
autres il vient couvrir oui bien sûr
mais il y à couvrir les besoins c'est un
régime qui existe depuis très longtemps
il vient couvrir les besoins et les
nécessités qui sont des cultures qui ne
sont pas assurables ça c'est un premier
élément est donc c'est principalement
les prairies parfois un certain nombre
de cultures ça peut être aussi parce
qu'on va avoir des conséquences on dit
trop peu sur des cultures dites pérenne
je pense à l'arboriculture aux petits
fruits le cassis les framboises vous
lasser le fond
en k1 risque de disparaître parce que
l'absence d'eau peut faire disparaître
et mourir ces plantes là et donc le
système de calamités va être mobilisée
deuxième élément on va mobiliser aussi
la capacité parce que c'est un sujet de
trésorerie pour beaucoup d'agriculteurs
c'est la capacité à acheter du fourrage
à acheter des compléments alimentaires
pour leurs animaux et donc on va
mobiliser la pac en disant confond les
versements pâques c'est 50% converse de
16 octobre et on va être plutôt à 75 %
ce qui permet de remettre dans la
machine si je peux dire de la trésorerie
pour les essais 1 milliard et un
milliard et demi fin milliard et demi de
plus qui ont versé en avance de phase
qui permettront aux agriculteurs de
pouvoir pour une part d'entre eux et
puis après on va évaluer ce que vous
disiez à juste titre les besoins
complémentaires pour regarder ce qu'ils
sont vraiment dans des situations
d'impasse pour répondre à leurs besoins
et ça ça va se dérouler dans les
semaines qui viennent ce qu'il va y
avoir des conséquences sur les prix
est-ce que ça on peut déjà le mesurer
sur les prix alimentaires alors il ya
les principales conséquences des prix
alimentaires vous l'avez vu on l'a tous
eu c'est l'airé les conséquences de la
guerre en ukraine puisque le prix des
céréales est un prix qui a monté très
puissamment à partir alors il avait
commencé à monter avant mais qu'à monter
puissamment à partir de la crise
l'ukrainienne à date on peut pas dire ça
parce que c'est un sujet plutôt d'accès
et de trésorerie mais en tout cas il
faut être vigilant pour faire en sorte
que ne viennent pas se surajouter à
cette question ukrainienne et à
l'inflation qui lie à la crise du crédit
n'est ni une affaire qui tourne nature
il pourrait y avoir un mécanisme de
compensation si tel était le mot ya déjà
des ça c'est un autre registre le
registre pouvoir d'achat c'est une
registre inflation mais à date ce n'est
pas ça qui est le sujet principal le
sujet principal dans le milieu agricole
c'est physique que les agriculteurs
puissent avoir accès pour des questions
de trésorerie à de l'alimentation
animale est ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui
ce matin marc fesneau à tous les
agriculteurs les éleveurs qui vous
écoutent ce matin ça va être comme ça
tous les ans où il ya une pierre une
vision des années qui viennent mais
c'est ça c'est le moyen et long terme et
c'est là dessus qu'il faut travailler à
la vérité quand vous êtes face à des
agriculteurs quand on est sur le terrain
qui ont eu parfois gel grêle sécheresse
le tout dans l'impact ans qui est de 12
mois il ya une forme de désespérance
avec le sentiment pour le monde agricole
que de crise en crise leurs capacités
productives et de confond la
souveraineté qui est la nôtre elle
risque diminué donc on a besoin de
travailler sur ce qu'on appelle la
résilience est à dire la capacité des
systèmes à être raisonnée est repensé
dans un dérèglement climatique qui va
durer c'est à dire quoi faire des
provisions
et j'en ai de la production et nature de
production qu'on fait évoluer par
exemple on bosse beaucoup sur le maïs
mais a déjà un certain nombre et culture
qui se sont orientés vers d'autres
productions qui permettent de se
substituer maïs qui est très demandeur
en haut il ya travaillent en bio par
exemple oui par exemple il ya d'autres
il ya d'autres solutions qui peuvent
être trouvés c'est de travailler aussi
sur les réserves en eau parce qu'au fond
il faut faire en agriculture ce qu'on
conseille à chacun d'entre nous quand on
a une maison c'est on récupère l'eau de
pluie quand il y en a trop pour pouvoir
arroser son jardin c'est exactement le
même système parce que l'eau en
agriculture pardon de répéter une
évidence sans eau il n'ya pas
d'agriculture c'est un combat multi
millénaire le combat du monde agricole
pour accéder à l'eau et donc il va
falloir aussi qu'on travaille sur ces
sujets là puis les pratiques agricoles
ce qu'on appelle l'agroécologie en
particulier qui permettent d'être
d'avoir des systèmes qui soit plus
résistant si je peux dire à ces
dérèglements climatiques on va y revenir
évidemment à la gestion nous parce que
c'est un enjeu primordial à l'avenir de
l'agriculture également avec vous marc
fesneau ministre de l'agriculture tout
d'abord 8h40 le fil info ce qu'il faut
retenir de l'actualité de ce mardi c'est
avec louise belin
1 c'est l'heure de la rentrée pour
l'exécutif elisabeth bornes et emmanuel
macron dînent ensemble à l'elysée ce
soir au menu notamment le pouvoir
d'achat la réforme du chômage et la
planification écologique il se prépare
avant le premier conseil des ministres
prévue demain l'hôpital de corbeil
essonnes en région parisienne n'a pas
payé les 10 millions de dollars de
rançon réclamée par les hackers qui ont
piraté le système informatique de
l'établissement ce week end depuis les
admissions aux urgences et l'accès aux
dossiers des patients sont très
fortement perturbé la direction
n'envisage pas un retour à la normale
avant plusieurs semaines trois policiers
suspendus aux états unis après une
arrestation particulièrement musclée en
arkansas dimanche une vidéo montrant un
homme plaqué au sol et tabassés par les
agents circulent sur les réseaux sociaux
plusieurs enquêtes sont en cours
pénalisé parole en voler du gaz qui
nourrit l'inflation et augmente les
risques de récession en europe l'euro
passe sous la parité avec le dollar la
monnaie européenne elle n'a jamais
atteint un niveau aussi bas depuis son
entrée en circulation il ya 20 ans
franceinfo
le 8 30 france info jean françois
achilli ces menaces l'eau est avec nous
marc fesneau le ministre de
l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire marc fesneau vous évoquez la
gestion de l'eau écouter ce qu'on a dit
la présidente de la fnsea
christiane lambert qui était l'invité
vendredi dernier de nos confrères de
france inter comment se fait-il
qu'aujourd'hui les pays là bas et le
danemark qui sont plus au nord que la
france se stockent plus d'eau que la
france nous avons un blocage idéologique
en france sur ce sujet on a besoin d'eux
aujourd'hui tous les pays qui tiennent
leur agriculture ont stocké plus d'eau
que nous en france nous n'utilisons que
1,7 pour cent de l'eau de pluie qui
tombent du ciel c'est plus de 20% en
espagne face à une eau plus rares il
faut une gestion plus intelligente une
irrigation de résilience aux rares
créneaux donc blocage idéologique nous
explique christiane lambert les
écologistes sont hostiles à l'idée de
stocker l'eau pour l'agriculture oui
alors après il faut simplement regarder
la réalité des choses je le disais tout
à l'heure c'est sans eau il n'ya pas
l'agriculture ce qu'on mange c'est de
l'eau quand vous mangez une salade quand
vous mangez des tomates quand vous
mangez multiplier les produits c'est 90
95 % d'eau donc il ya besoin d'eau pour
faire pousser ses pardon d'avoir avoir
répété cette évidence deux vous regardez
un certain nombre de régions j'étais
donc dans les alpes de haute provence au
début août s'il n'y avait pas un certain
nombre de réserves en eau je pense au
barrage de serre ponçon et autres qui
avait été créée il ya certaines données
il ya des dizaines d'années on se
retrouverait dans la situation d'être en
berne au gua nous sommes en retard sans
doute nous étions un climat nous étions
d'un pays d'un climat tempéré donc des
régions type provence alpes côte d'azur
avait développé à l'époque parce qu'il
avait déjà cette conscience de risque
méditerranéen au sens taux risque de
sécheresse qu'il y avait une difficulté
mais étant un climat plutôt tempérée
nous mettons n'étions pas à penser l'eau
comme denrée rare et une denrée à régler
dont vous allez enclenchée si oui alors
c'est pas complètement nouveau parce que
pardon de vous dire qu'on a travaillé
mon prédécesseur julien de nord modéré
beaucoup travaillé ce qu'on appelait le
varennes de l'eau qui visait à
développer trois axes le premier le
système assurantiel peut être qu'on y
reviendra le deuxième c'était les
changements des pratiques et le
troisième c'est la création de réserves
en eau pourquoi parce qu en gros le
l'ume d'eau qui tombe chaque année est
le même la difficulté c'est que cette
eau ne tombe pas de façon régulière en
gros vous aviez dans un département
conduit tôt que oui dans un département
comme le mien vous aviez en grossissant
mm d'eau qui tombaient chaque année et
on pouvait presque divisé par 12 c'était
à peu près le volume qui tombait tous
les mois sauf que par exemple dans mon
département il est tombé à l'est une
dizaine de millimètres d'eau depuis le
15 juin donc on a besoin et donc à la
fin il y aura 600 mm et donc a besoin
quand il ya trop d'eau de pouvoir la
stocker pour pouvoir la rue richer voix
richir pour pouvoir la restituer quand
il y aura des périodes de pénurie vous
savez marc fesneau toutes les critiques
qui sont faites à l'encontre des
réserves d'eau qui pourrait selon les
écologistes favoriser la sécheresse
parce que ça empêche l'eau de
s'infiltrer dans les sols parce que ça
favorise l'évaporation parce que ça
confisqué aussi une denrée commune à des
fins particulières alors certes faire
pousser de l'aliment mais demain est
planté et donc favoriser l'alimentation
mais en tout cas il ya un choix qui est
fait est qui et qui est une forme de
confiscation disent les eaux et ses
réserves j'inviterais réponde à ça
pardon de juger les faits mais je vous
ai un peu coupé mes premiers éléments
regardons ce que font les autres pays
européens la présidente lambert a raison
de le dire dans beaucoup de pays
européens on travaille sur les questions
d'eau sans dogmatisme en essayant
d'avancer sur le sujet
deuxième élément la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est un bien commun la
capacité qu'ont à s'ouvrir c'est un bien
commun donc quand les agriculteurs
prennent de l'eau ces propos c'est pour
alimenter des végétaux en eau bien sûr
qu'il puisse pousser ce qu on pourrait
le dire mais les nantis imaginez que
l'on favorise des cultures qui se met
moins gourmands et saison de chez en
train de vous dire on fait les deux mais
il faut il ya des sujets quand vous avez
quatre mois sans eau du tout et c'est ce
qui s'est passé cet été c'est 100 au
plus des épisodes caniculaires ce qui
fait du stress hydrique encore plus fort
pour les plantes et bien tout ça s'il
n'y a pas d'eau à la fin il n'y a pas de
production agricole donc il faut
simplement se le dire il faut l'eau qui
rentre dans les nappes c'est l'eau quand
elle tombe tranquillement qui je peux
dire quand il tombe 100 mm comme il est
arrivé y compris dans des territoires
qu'ils n'y étaient pas habitués en une
demi journée setola elles filent
directement à la mer donc cette eau là
ne vient pas à remplir les nappes donc
il faut prélever ce qui l est ce que
sont les éclats d'os qu'on appelle les
éclats d'os les excès d'eau viennent
désormais parce qu'on a une arythmie de
la pluviométrie il pluviométrique et moi
je suis dans un département la région
centre val de loire le paie les pays de
loire qui sont à côté vous avez
maintenant des pluviométries dans une
jeu que nous ne connaissions pas donc ça
veut dire dans tous les départements il
faut favoriser il faut combiner les
choses j'essaie de ne pas répondre
dogmatisme par le dogmatisme il faut
qu'on gagne le combiné les choses des
changements pratiques des changements
d'un seulement et puis il ya besoin
d'eau et donc il faut pardon du thème
tranquillement posé les termes du débat
et il ya bien des endroits d'ailleurs
j'étais l'autre jour en maine et loire
on voit bien que agriculteurs
associations environnementales services
de l'état et autres usagers se sont mis
autour de la table et parfois ça a
permis de maintenir les étiages si la
scène est encore à un niveau d'étiage
assez élevé si encore de l'eau à ce
niveau là dans la seine c'est parce
qu'il ya bien des ouvrages qui sont en
amont et qui existent et qui ont été
créés d'ailleurs avec une volonté qui
est une volonté de lutter contre les
inondations en particulier en région
parisienne donc il faut aussi développer
le multi usages et puis dernier point
pardon d'être non mais c'est un sujet
important il faut qu'on développe aussi
la capacité à mobiliser de l'eau on est
le pays d'europe où là des pays d'europe
qui mobilise le moins l'eau issue des
stations de traitement de l'eau donc
vous pourrez vous fait quoi alors vous
allez enclenché tout de suite oui mais
on y trônent dans le cadre du varennes
de l'eau il ya un certain nombre de
projets qui ont été posées sur la table
l'idée maintenant c'est d'accélérer et
c'est ça qui recycle lots annoncés 13
ans mais l'eau est recyclée simplement
maintenant il faut la réutilisant
l'agriculture et donc cédé que parfois
des contraintes normatives mais là aussi
on trouvera sûrement des âmes bien
pensantes qui nous expliqueront que non
peut pas les réutiliser les agriculteurs
ils sont prêts à ça bien sûr dans leur
chasse surtout sur un certain nombre de
cultures ça pose pas de difficultés
particulières enfin nous ne sommes pas
sur une île isolée du reste du monde en
italie c'est 15 % de l'eau issue des
stations qui réutilise et en france et 1
% que je sache des locales ainsi qu'aux
logique aussi oui mais mais essayons de
poser tranquillement les débats de lever
les blocages psychologiques et de
répondre à la question qui est l'eau est
une denrée précieuse et donc il faut
l'interpréter comme une denrée précieuse
et donc si on peut la réutiliser par
exemple dans ce domaine là on fait et si
on peut la stocker quand il ya des excès
de pluviométrie est bien là stocks marc
fesneau est ce qu'il n'ya pas au four
deux visions qui s'affrontent la
question c'est quel est le modèle
désormais d'une agriculture résilient
que vous disiez tout à l'heure
respectueuse de l'environnement capable
de nourrir en même temps la population
propose d'entendre cendrars goal qui est
député europe ecologie les verts du bas
rhin elle était sur france info notre
invité avec céline a selon elle a
proposé de de consommer - devions des
mieux alors manger moins de viande mais
manger mieux de viande ça veut dire de
la viande qui est produite chez nous par
des paysans qui font vivre nos campagnes
aujourd'hui l'essentiel de cette viande
que l'on consomme elle vient de l'autre
bout du monde elle de répondre à des
modes de production qui ne sont pas ceux
qu'on voudrait elles ne produisent pas
dans la chine moins de viande oeufs
mieux de viande dix sept députés
écologistes il ya deux choses d'abord il
ya une inexactitude ce serait tellement
bien dans ce pays composent des sujets
dans la réalité de ce qu'ils sont
l'essentiel de la viande qui est
consommé en france ne vient pas de
l'étranger et liens de france pour faut
arrêter de dire des choses qui sont des
sornettes ne prenons pas de 2k
minoritaire ou des sujets qui sont
mineurs des sujets majeurs l'essentiel
de la viande produite deux donc ça c'est
assez factuel il suffit de vérifier de
voir que l'essentiel de la viande
consommée en france et de la viande qui
est produite en france n'est pas
forcément nourris uniquement avec des
plantes et des fourrages à l'enduit
vente non mais c'est encore un autre
sujet d'ailleurs le plan protéines qui a
voulu développer le président la
république c'est un plan d'autonomie
alimentaire parce qu'on en a besoin de
travailler sur l'alimentation et de
sortir effectivement du soja qui a été
une alimentation qui était le produit de
la déforestation et les éleveurs
travaillent là dessus on n'a pas attendu
les uns ou les autres pour le faire mon
premier sujet essayons de poser les
sujets tels qu'ils sont et dans la
vérité des faits est le deuxième sujet
ça c'est assez juste c'est comme
consommateurs nous mêmes qu'est ce qu'on
a dans l'acte de consommer il ya un
consommateur et puis un citoyen et quand
on consomme des produits français en
particulier sur la viande on a derrière
il faut penser derrière à ce qui est
derrière le produit qu'on consomme et
c'est un agriculteur un éleveur qui
permet d'entretenir le paysage qui
permet d'apporter des choses en terme de
biodiversité qui permet aussi d'éviter
parfois dans certains secteurs que sas
en friche et qu'on puisse avoir des feux
de forêt donc ne nous consommateurs
collectivement nous avons dans notre
acte de consommation quelque chose qui
est de l'ordre d'un puissant levier
aussi pour l'agriculture en effet la
culture la viande bovine c'est sans
doute ce qui consomme le plus d'eau dans
toutes les cultures animal évidemment
qu'il faut qu'il faut énormément de
litres pour produire un kiwi légende
donc on pousse à poser la question quand
même de ce choix tendanciellement on
voit bien d'ailleurs qu'on est plutôt
sur une décroissance de la consommation
de viande mais
assis autour de ce bureau de dire il
faut yakafokon et ses colliers une
tendance lourde qui soit celle là par
ailleurs il ya un sujet central sait on
ne réussira pas ces transitions s'il n'y
a pas de recherche du juste prix mais
les cercles à dire de rémunération les
justes prix d'accord mais les circuits
courts par exemple c'est la bonne idée
oui mais ça met les circuits courts il
se développe il existe enfin 90 % de la
consommation ne se fait pas en circuit
court et se fait dans la grande
distribution et c'est là que nous avons
comme consommateurs des choix que le
devon perron on a eu beaucoup d'espoir
au moment de la crise qu vite dans cette
crise qui était par ailleurs dramatique
qui était au fond le retour aux sources
que court un peu forcé que nous étions
du confinement et puis la nature est
revenu au galop pardon de cette
expression est au fond on est revenu
dans les circuits de grande distribution
classique et donc là aussi comme
consommateur on doit regarder mais c'est
vrai que les circuits courts sont ils et
elles vous dites aux consommateurs
aujourd'hui au vu de l'été qu'on vient
de traverser qu'est-ce que vous
conseillez tendance à dire que dans les
actes de consommation que nous avons et
je connais les contingences aussi
l'inflation mais on a essayé de poser un
certain nombre de sujets sur la table au
gouvernement de faire en sorte qu'à
chaque fois qu'on produit un acte de
consommation on cherche
l'agriculteur qui est derrière et la
rémunération qui est derrière est le
juste prix c'est pas forcément le bas
prix parce que sinon on incite plutôt à
une agriculture qui soit dévalorisé sac
facile de savoir quand vous vous baladez
dans l'allier avec sang-froid dgc
potager vous voyez bien quand s'est
produit en france vous voyez bien quand
il ya une rémunération qui est indiquée
enfin il ya un certain nombre
d'indicateurs et premiers indicateurs
qui permettent de le faire 8h51 sur
france info marc fesneau notre invité
ministre de l'agriculture on reprend cet
entretien dans un instant tout d'abord
ce qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité de
ce mardi louise buyens pour le fil info
le feu ne progresse plus dans le massif
des alpilles dans les bouches-du-rhône
près de 120 hectares de végétation ont
brûlé depuis hier après midi 250
pompiers restent mobilisés ce matin
l'incendié n'est pas encore fixée un
garçon et une fille des mineurs sont
morts hier soir dans un accident de la
route à lyon une ambulance privée qui
partait en intervention les a percutés
il circulait sur une trottinette sur la
voie dédiée aux secours et aux bus
gérald darmanin veut ouvrir des lieux de
rééducation et de redressement pour les
mineurs délinquants de mayotte encadrés
par des militaires le ministre de
l'intérieur et des autres maires annonce
qu'il va faire des propositions au
président dans les prochains jours
emmanuel macron qui avait déjà évoqué
cette idée pendant la campagne pour la
présidentielle
bientôt des formations à destiné à
l'armée ukrainienne est dispensée par
l'europe proposition du chef de la
diplomatie européenne elle sera discutée
la semaine prochaine par les ministres
de la défense des 27 états membres
franceinfo
le 8 30 france info jean françois
achilli céline a slow avec toujours dans
le studio de france info marc fesneau
ministre de l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire alors c'est une
forme de rentrer demain premier conseil
des ministres autour d' emmanuel macron
à l'elysée on va évoquer évidemment les
grands sujets de la rentrée le budget
aussi sans doute les arbitrages ont été
annoncés par gabriela talent rallonge de
3 milliards gül 3 pour la transition
écologique et avec à l'intérieur un demi
milliard pour l'agriculture est ce que
ça veut dire que l'un de vos enjeux pour
la rentrée marque chez nous ce sera
d'arriver à trouver votre place dans une
priorité donnée à la transition
écologique mais l'agriculture par nature
elle a beaucoup de voies et moyens de
trouver des solutions dans les questions
de règlement des dérèglements
climatiques de rapatriement
tiraillements je crois que quand vous
parlez avec les agriculteurs d'abord ils
sont les premiers à connaître le
dérèglement climatique suffit de parler
aux viticulteurs et qui vous montre les
tableaux des dates de vendanges entre ce
qui était le tableau au mois deux de
leurs parents et ce qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui donc ils savent ce qu'elles
dérèglement climatique parce qu'ils
l'ont perçu physiquement perçu et puis
de il le vivra aussi comme une crise on
en a parlé c'est à dire qu'en permanence
ils sont victimes du dérèglement
climatique et par ailleurs ils ont des
solutions parce que l'agriculture est un
formidable outil si vous me permettez
cette expression qui permet par exemple
le stockage carbone la forêt aussi on en
a pas parlé mais la forêt qui est aussi
dans mon périmètre c'est un formidable
outil pour le stockage carbone donc
l'agriculture elle est à la fois
victimes du dérèglement climatique comme
on en a longuement parlé tout à l'heure
et de elle porte des solutions qui
permettront aussi de lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique et donc on est au
coeur et sait pas par hasard que dans
les budgets qui sont dédiés aux sujets
écologiques de transition écologique et
de lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique l'agriculture soit au coeur
du sujet vous diriez marc fesneau par
delà le le sujet qui est important de
l'agriculture que c'est une rentrée
inquiète
c'est une rentrée oui écouter quand on
regarde le ce qu'est le monde
actuellement c'est inquiétant pour
plusieurs motifs d'abord la crise je
craignais un peu le climat qui sous tend
ce conseil des ministres qui est oui au
delà de ce qu'on a évoqué qui est qui
est un climat un peu anxiogène le climat
du dérèglement climatique crée de
l'anxiété et donc à nous au delà de de
la réponse à l'immédiateté d'essayer
tresser des perspectives que j'ai essayé
de faire de vendre ou de trouver des
solutions à la question c'est pas d'être
posée sur son siège et dire il ya qu'à
faut qu'on il faudrait il aurait fallu
c'est de faire et c'est ce qu'on fait et
on le découvre pas cet été parce qu'un
certain nombre de mesures que j'ai
évoquées qui avait été prise avant puis
deuxième jeu donc ça c'est un sujet
d'angoissé puis un deuxième sujet quelle
actrice ukrainienne qui porte son lot
d'angoissés en termes d'inflation qui
porte son nom d'ambroise en termes
guerriers disons les choses parce que
les rodomontades des uns et des autres
en russie peuvent être inquiétante et
globalement le sentiment que la tension
internationale est à son comble dans un
dérèglement globale du monde épie
troisième élément la crise énergétique
produite par la crise ukrainienne et
fait peser de lourdes menaces compris
sur de grands partenaires européens pour
pas dire les premiers je pense aux
allemands avec des risques sur
l'économie mondiale et donc on à
l'économie européenne donc évidemment
mais la question n'est pas forcément
pour nous quand vous êtes responsables
politiques de décrire la situation avec
des questions c'est d'essayer de trouver
des solutions ce qu'on a fait dans le
premier collective est ce qu'on risque
pas d'oublier très rapidement justement
avec toutes ces priorités tous ces
sources d'inquiétude ce qui s'est passé
cet été qu'on attende finalement l'été
prochain la prochaine s'échelonner
prochain ça qui font tant l'hiver arrive
on va est tranquille on aura du rouet et
dès qu'il a plus on aura réglé le
problème ce qui n'est pas le cas la
vérité on disait tout à l'heure vous
disais tout à l'heure
l'actualité chaude et puis là que le
travail qu'il faut faire de façon plus
discrète et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
aussi manier les deux parce qu'à un
moment moi je n'oublie pas je
n'oublierai pas ce qu'on a vécu cet été
et le gouvernement n'oubliera pas ce
qu'on a vécu cet été et donc mais nous
sommes dans une société de l'immédiateté
donc il faut faire des images et montrer
des choses et puis après on oublié un
truc un peu trop rapidement vous avez
raison mais il n'est nulle question pour
moi parce que les effets de ce qui s'est
passé cet été d'abord malheureusement et
je ne dis jamais autre chose aux
agriculteurs sas multipliera et donc la
nécessité de règles du dérèglement
climatique
face aux dérèglements climatiques c'est
de s'adapter donc ça c'est du temps long
et donc il faut qu'on accepte de
travailler sur le moyen long terme et
c'est la difficulté qu'ont pris pour
installer deux jeunes agriculteurs sait
on est sur plusieurs générations qui
vont subir logique règlement climatique
en agriculture comme dans d'autres
domaines et donc notre responsabilité
c'est de préparer le terrain pour faire
en sorte que dans une ou deux
générations on ait essayé de résoudre ce
problème là mais dans l'intervalle il
faut aussi s'adapter donc cédé deux
pieds sur lequel il faut travailler marc
fesneau vous fûtes ministre des
relations avec le parlement ce qui se
nomme ce qui se passe dans l'hémicycle
avec les oppositions quelle soit nuque
ou ou est reine il n'y a pas de dialogue
possible je sais qu'il ya cette
initiative renaissance de vouloir
préparer en amont co-construire
supprimer des amendements raccourcir non
pas les circuits courts mais raccourcir
le débat parlementaire ça ne marchera
pas cette histoire mais c'est l'arrêt ce
projet les 10 le lendemain des élections
législatives c'est la responsabilité de
chacun notre nouveau gouvernement s'est
mis en situation de responsabilité donc
notre responsabilité c'est de pouvoir
réformer de pouvoir légiférer parfois
y'a pas besoin d'ailleurs de légiférer
on peut avancer sans légiférer on est un
pays qui adore légiférer pour avancer on
peut aussi faire des tas de choses sans
avoir besoin de produire de la loi un
pays qui est un peu malade de sa
propension à essayer de régler en
permanence les sujets par la loi quand
bien des pays vous regarderez le nombre
de lois qui sont votées dans d'autres
pays bon mais ceci étant il faut voter
des lois faut voter des lois budgétaires
nous on est on est passé pas la question
d'être prêt à dialoguer on est prêt à
avancer on est prêt à réformer on est
prêt à résoudre les problèmes des
français parce que les français nous
regarde tous les députés et j'en étais
qui ont été élues et dans mois déjà ils
ont une responsabilité c'est de réseaux
des preuves défoncé pas d'organiser les
querelles et pas d'organiser son pré
carré pour les élections qui viendront
et donc nous on est prêt à travailler à
réformer est ce que d'autres le sont on
verra bien cet été un certain nombre ont
plutôt montré des signes qui sont pas
des mots dessine d'ailleurs de pollution
simplement décidé de lui qu'un bon
travail aux républicains mais parfois
certains se sont abstenus côté gauche
aussi c'est la capacité parfois à
s'extraire dans dix ans quel est
l'intérêt général au delà de mon intérêt
politique immédiat ou particuliers là
aussi faudrait qu'on sorte du temps qu
pour penser le temps long quand on est
sur les sujets qu'on a évoqué la
question de la transition écologique les
questions d'aidé de grande et règlements
géopolitique croyez pas on pourrait le
faire et quand vous regardez les
partenaires européens ou d'autres pays à
l'extérieur de l'union européenne c'est
ce qu'on fait quand on est on se croit
ou on s'estime responsable on termine
sur une main tendue oui mais dans sa
jean françois achilli qui me connaît
depuis longtemps c'est que depuis
longtemps c'est ce que je pense donc je
n'ai pas changé de pied après il faut
être la main tendue fauqué demain il
faut que j'en ai une pour la saisir
après les français seront jugés à la
vérité c'est ce qui se passera merci
beaucoup marc fesneau d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin ministre de
l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci à vous jean françois
qui lit on se retrouve demain et en
attendant restez avec nous bien sûr sur
france info
[Musique]